[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday December
10th and I have very exciting news
whenever she watches the video Sara
always makes fun of me because when I
get excited I talk in a really
high-pitched voice so I'm gonna try to
do that again
good morning Hank it's Monday December
10th and I have very exciting news no
that doesn't work it just doesn't sound
genuinely excited I mean I understand
why it's hard for my wife to accept but
the fact of the matter is that my
genuine excited voice is the voice of a
fangirl I mean if I'm like I have very
exciting news
everyone will be like no he doesn't he's
full of it but if I'm like oh my god
such exciting news then everyone's gonna
be like that guy is really excited
I know because he sounds like an 11 year
old girl at a Jonas Brothers concert
anyway Hank you may recall that the last
time I had very exciting news the very
exciting news was that I had just
finished cataloging my home library no
Hank I certainly don't want to take
anything away from the Herculean task
that is cataloging one's home library
but this news is even more exciting Hank
you may recall that last year I
published a book called an abundance of
katherines
it's gonna be a movie hopefully one day
eventually Hank the Catharines movie
deal has been in the works for a really
really long time but over the weekend
everyone finally agreed to everything
and now it's done and I can tell you
about it and I'm very excited that
Katherine's is going to be a movie
hopefully one day eventually by the way
the reason I keep saying hopefully one
day eventually is that these things take
a long time like for instance my first
novel Looking for Alaska has been in
movie development for like a year and a
half now and is still in development
another good example of how long it can
take is the excellent book Beowulf which
was released I believe eleven hundred
years ago and then the movie came out
last month but an abundance of
katherines the movie will have a much
smaller budget than Beowulf the movie so
hopefully we'll be able to get it going
a little faster Hank there are several
reasons why I'm really excited that east
of Doheny option an abundance of
katherines to turn it into a movie
reason one is that I've always thought
that it could be kind of a funny cool
interesting movie reason 2 is that east
of Doheny is an awesome production
company that's interested in a lot of
the same kind of movies I'm interested
in and reason three is that they want me
to write the screenplay and that's very
exciting because I've always wanted to
write a screenplay and plus I think it
would be great fun to hang out with
Hassan and Lindsey and all the other
characters from an abundance of
katherines and also like a lot of
authors I'm very excited about the
of having some creative control over the
movie that gets made out of my book so
of course I would like to write the
screenplay for an abundance of
katherines but unfortunately I'm on
strike that's right Hank I'm striking in
my jammy pants hey hey pencils down
Hollywood's a Union town and so I guess
is Indianapolis I know I need to work on
my chanting Hank but I've only been on
strike for like one day Hank I don't
know if you heard but the studio moguls
showing the kind of fortitude and
generosity of spirit for which they're
widely respected walked away from the
negotiating table last week now Hank I
know that the studio moguls are watching
our show because God knows they're not
watching the craft they're putting on
television right now American Gladiators
really that's what you're gonna bring
back and I have a little message for the
studio moguls get back to the table as
Hassan would say daddy wants to make a
movie so Hank that's my very exciting
news I'm sorry that my pitch got so high
but I'm very very happy I'm so happy
that I forgive you for saying in your
last video that I lie about my height
when you and I both know that I'm really
genuinely 6 feet 1 inches tall or at
least I am now Hank I want to say a
quick thanks to everyone at East of
Doheny for believing in my book and to
all the agents and everybody who made
this happen I'm sorry about the thing on
my nose but trust me it looked worse
before I popped it I'll see you tomorrow